he feel especially where he grew up in a  very individualistic mindset where it  was all about I need to do this I can't  have help I can't yeah but the thing is  because you've got married yeah and  you've had a child which is it should be  the other way around so he before he  married you he should have been working  on himself and came with the money blah  blah blah and said I'm ready you  accepted where he was and he accepted  where you was when you got married now  you can't go you can't put your child  you know back inside your womb and then  she regrows again but what I am saying  is where you are you have to work  through it together because because  you're working separately